[Applause]
[Music]
howdy y'all
dead what do you say to a cocktail coach
lasso oh the same thing i'd say to diane
sawyer if she ever asked me out on a
date yes please
live from the dog track it's richmond
with eight stray ties
how many more matches before you hit the
panic button there's two buttons i never
like hitting that's panic and snooze
i don't care what our record is it's all
about believing that everything's gonna
work out in the end
exactly as it's supposed to it isn't the
idea of never give up on them things we
always talk about in sports and
shouldn't that apply to people too
it's a beautiful metaphor for many of
life's journeys
[Music]
the team's just a little unlucky maybe
we should bring in a sports psychologist
brought you a little something something
for your first day of work here
[Music]
i don't eat sugar really i've never met
someone don't eat sugar
only heard about them they all live in
this godless place called santa monica
[Music]
you got a fever for the flavored little
girl talk don't you this trap i've been
seeing
jon sneimos no his name's john
wingsnike like at a sports bar like
monday nights wings night down at pj
flats would you please stop
rule number one even though it's called
girl talk sometimes it needs to be more
like girl listen
what's ted doing probably i'm sick
closest thing you can find to a dodge
ram
back home if the team was playing poorly
we don't call him unlucky what do we
call him coach
new york jets
you